[Music]
okay we're back here on overtime and I'm
gonna give you guys the first shot to
respond to the editorial because I'm
sure you were sitting there stewing as I
was saying that the Republican Party is
the party of fantasy but your rebuttal
to speech I've heard Republicans give
about Democrats my whole life so you
know it's I mean that's that's the
debate we have right which side is being
fiscally fantastic I know but one side
more has the facts on their side I mean
if you don't believe in global warming
then you're going against every
scientist in the world that the
temperatures haven't increased for the
last ten years that's completely wrong
complain it's been the hottest year ever
that like eight out of the last ten
years of the hottest years ever where
were you getting this where are you
[Applause]
trying to make funny I'm just saying we
must not be reading the same language
you don't really think global warming is
happening in manmade no I don't
okay you do it what do you concede that
ninety something percent percent of
scientists do think that there's a lot
of politicization of the global the
climate scientists are paid off that's
right yeah that's why scientists are I'm
mansions and wearing
talk to MIT Richard Lindsay he's one of
the people who audits estate if I
reconsider blacks a persuasive case that
it's not what you really need to do I
think yes is if you could get both sides
of this to agree well okay who are the
references that we're going to say who
are the gold standards instead of
arguing what the gold standards are the
climatologist the scientist and they're
all on the same side and by the way 20
years ago your party did not deny it was
happening that wasn't the position of
the Republican Party in the Bob Dole era
it was cap and trade which is now the
Democrat position what happened how did
we go from it's happening so now it's
not happening at all well there's a
couple of different points right there
is temperature variability and what's
causing that right so is it being caused
by man we don't know it might be being
caused by that and then there's the
question of if it is being caused by a
man if it's true that computer models by
climate scientists can predict to the
second decimal point in 2050 three the
temperature will increase by 0.5
centigrade what can we do about that
what are the are we in a specified you
would say that there is you you
suggested that there was variability so
you do say that there is climate change
you might not say that there's global
warming but you do say that there is
climate change happening global
temperatures go up they go down there's
there's a curacy we're getting more
extreme we're getting you know the
consensus though I mean well we're only
humans we will never have a perfect
answer because there will be no God who
comes down and says this is the answer
so we can only go by consensus which
means like 100 years ago
everyone didn't believe in Darwin's
theory and then it was over well maybe
because we thought so if we have over 90
percent of the people who are trained in
the field so it's 90 percent of the like
point oo 1 percent of the people who are
knowledgeable isn't that overwhelming
you know I don't have any sponsor bility
because the tradition has been good or
the anchors to just basically present
both sides of the global warming story
so those who don't believe on one side
and also believe on the other as though
there's an equivalence
Thomas Friedman had agretti and he said
if they came out for some one side said
the world was flat the headline in the
paper would be two sides disagree on
size and shape of world
yeah and Bill is right I mean either the
overwhelming number of scientists in
this field will say that there is
climate change happening and the globe
is warming that waters arise and it was
man-made and that it is man-made and
that there is a dispute even as Paul
Ryan I said there is a dispute about
what you can do about it you know and
there is some dispute about what you can
do about it but the facts in cording to
the science are you will find some
scientists who disagree but the vast
majority will tell you that there is
global warming happening I think we can
do about it I would be great for our
economy to alternative sources of energy
but but Arianna saying I agree with if
you move to well what are some of the
solutions because everybody wants less
air pollution and you know maybe we can
get together on a lot of these things
alternative energy I still think we
should drill our own doggone oil and I
don't want to take this opportunity to
remind you that when Obama was elected
in January oh nine gas was a dollar 83 a
gallon that would be cheap for me to
remind you that the president's fault
[Laughter]
trace it back to me how it's his fault
just breaking the permitting process
more cumbersome taken longer in the
duration and issue and less permits I
mean there is a supply and demand if you
chose open drilling in the Gulf of
Mexico the Liberals because there's the
possibility of some kind of war with
Iran and instability in the Middle East
the the person that has been saying tamp
this down it is irresponsible to talk
about strikes against the Iranians is
actually in the white house what's so
he's you know supply and demand you
increase your supply and the price is
going to go down and he has not done
anything that can increase the supply so
you know if we really believe that
industrialization is the cause of global
warming then what you're really saying
is Africa can't become part of the
developed world you're saying that India
shouldn't be a developed country because
if those come if those if India
[Applause]
can't become part of the developer
because that they do they're gonna
pollute more they're gonna consume more
fossil fuels they're gonna use more
energy they're gonna do all the things
that the environmentalists oppose so
what I really say can become guiding all
of them to poverty I think we even allow
them to become prosperous but wait this
is a false argument like if we don't use
fossil fuels you're consigned to poverty
that's ridiculous solar panels are gonna
fuel world energy too that they will
some years ago do you think cars are
gonna replace horses
unicorns that can power the world first
of all it's happening in other countries
around the world those but China is
doing it already of course India is
doing it already it's not efficient
that's why Solyndra went bankrupt
nothing is worse it's the most
subsidized form of energy there is and
in the lease I know I know Democrats
hate to hear it but the lease subsidized
energy is fossil fuel but the internet
didn't come into existence perfect at
the beginning I want to get a better
than what already honest it because I
found it I found some level for
agreement here that but you know an
all-of-the-above energy strategy is
sound and it has lots of political
consensus and you know I have supported
research at the University of Georgia
for algae and for a non-eligible
edible sweet potatoes and you know
there's a lot of good things that are
out there that we are investing in but I
think at the same time I'll G yes sir
come on that must be [ __ ] right man
solar an hours cool this guy is just
you know but but any plant that has
sugar in it you can get energy out of
and that's what Brazil still with
sugarcane right now so I mean there are
things that we can do alright we didn't
get to one question but mine was fun
thank you folks thank you real-time
would do more ask bill has guest your
questions right after the show at
hbo.com